[Musique]
c'est une grande journée dédiée à
l'entrepreneuriat au sens large avec
toutes ses composantes dans un esprit
festif et promotionnelles de tout ce que
nous pouvons faire ici à saint quentin
et en ile de france ont fait avoir des
entreprises du territoire
les thématiques couvre champ très large
l'emploi l'innovation
l'environnement la création d'entreprise
[Musique]
et le programme du bic tour est très
dense entre des témoignages
d'entrepreneurs des conseils pour
entreprendre ou encore la découverte de
métiers la thématique de l'emploi
résonnera aussi au vélodrome national
avec le big job dating entre 13h30 et
18h30
on aura des temps forts autour
d'animations de conférences animées par
l'ensemble des entreprises des acteurs
économiques du bassin de saint quentin
en yvelines tout bien souhaité se
mobiliser là sur des thématiques très
large l'innovation la création
d'entreprise l'emploi les métiers de
demain une émission très atypique qui
s'appelle vivent ta ville et qui nous
permettra de mettre en avant tout la
valeur de 50 ans du lean un événement
important également pour montrer aussi
la dimension de cette journée qui quels
une opération combinée impliquant en fin
de journée sur france 2030 avec un
aspect industriel aujourd'hui qui est
important dans le cadre de la relance
économique
et la journée se conclura par un concert
du groupe skip the use pour plus
d'informations notamment pour participer
à cet événement rendez vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran